Hello. And welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live.
Am your host, Rawkode.
Now before we begin, I just wanna take
a moment to thank my employer, Equinix Medal.
They provide the time for me to invest
and producing the show and creating
cloud native content for us all to learn
together.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
Kubernetes
and specifically,
auto scaling on Kubernetes. And to do that
today,
I am join.
Well, I messed that one up. I'm joined
by my friend,
Guy Templeton, an engineer for Skyscanner
and the co chair of SIG Auto Scaling.
Hey, Guy. How are you? Hi. Good. Thanks.
You?
Yeah. I'm doing alright. I mean, until I
I removed myself from the stream instead of
bringing you in. You know,
that's the joy of of live TV, I
guess. So
do you wanna give us a quick introduction
about yourself, and then we'll talk about what
we're gonna cover today?
Yep. So
as
you already mentioned, I'm a software engineer at
Skyscanner,
my
focus there has generally been on certain internal
developer tooling,
enabling Skyscanner's engineers to
deploy workloads
and build their code fast, etcetera.
As part of that, for the last two
years or so, I've been on the team
that has been building out our Kubernetes infrastructure
on top of AWS
and migrating
containerized workloads onto that.
And that's involved.
As part of that, I've sort of got
more and more involved in the Kubernetes community
over the time
with a particular focus on sort of cost
saving
and
auto scaling,
which is likely becoming
one of the co chairs of psychotic scaling.
Okay. Awesome.
I mean, so
let's start with the easiest question in the
world. How about that?
If I run my application on Kubernetes,
does it just magically auto scale by default?
I mean, that's a promise of Kubernetes. Right?
Unfortunately
not.
Kubernetes is clever, but but not quite clever
enough to yet
to figure out that it needs to scale
things magically
and how and what
where it should scale it, etcetera.
So that
as with a lot of Kubernetes, there's currently
a lot of dials there for people to
figure out like, to choose the way their
application scales.
That can potentially be a bit overwhelming at
the moment for users because there's so many
dials
for them to possibly change and and figure
out exactly how best to scale
their workloads,
how they expose the metrics they choose to
scale their workloads and make sure that Kubernetes
understands those.
And so that's that's what we'll try and
cover today.
Scaling both in horizontal sense
and choosing choosing your metrics, setting up those
pipelines to get metrics available for scaling,
as well as vertical auto scaling. So the
idea of adjusting
the resources on single pods to to meet
their requirements.
Okay. So
let's
continue with a little bit of background and
then I'll get my my screen shared and
we'll we'll get hands on with this stuff.
Now, I guess, the naive implementation and the
people and organizations teams that are adopting Kubernetes
may do is just to, you know, have
lots of deployments to the applications
and use the replicas field and say that
their spec. Set it to a big high
number to keep their traffic satisfied.
And that's not ideal. Right? You're you're what
you just said there was that, you know,
you're part of a cost savings initiative. It's
guys gonna have to reduce cost. And that
means scaling your application with the expected traffic
levels at any given time.
Would you say that using the replicas field
on a deployment spec is almost an anti
pattern?
I would say if you're doing that manually
yourself,
yeah, that's that's probably an active pattern.
I mean, a lot of these tools up
the hood will effectively be manipulating
those replica fields on a target, whether that's
a deployment
or similar.
But, yeah. I I think if if you're
if you're of the having to, like, go
in at, you know, say you've got protected
traffic spikes at eight in the morning for
some reason. If you're going in and, like,
an engineer is going in at 07:50 every
morning going better scale up, edit, compute, cut,
delete, deploy,
that that's that's probably an anti pattern. And
there's there are ways that you can achieve
that without having
to have an engineer manually edit A cron
job. Right?
Yeah. I mean, you could you could do
that. I'd still say it's not not not
the ideal solution.
Yeah. I mean, obviously, I'm
testing. Right? You know, we we want this
stuff to be slightly more sophisticated,
which is where HPAs and VPs come in.
You know, we actually Yeah.
We I I know that you're example. I
don't know if we're we're gonna cover it.
I'll I'll speculate. But, you know, we wanna
talk about using metrics from our applications to
understand
as the latency of the ninety fifth percentile
that we respond to our customers, but it
was an acceptable SLAs and scaling accordingly. Right?
I guess that. Exactly.
Alright. So all of the
stuff we're gonna cover today, you have published
to get up and it's public. Right? So
I can share this link? Yeah. Yep. Okay.
So we're gonna take a look at github.com/gjtempletonslash,
well, I'm not gonna read that out. It's
the Kubernetes
auto scaling by example.
I
haven't cloned it yet.
As I like to do with this show
is just discuss what I do upfront, which
is Yeah. Almost as little as possible.
I don't think it makes a lot of
sense for people to sit and watch me
spin up a Kubernetes cluster. So we do
have a Kubernetes cluster.
That's it. Good. It's
a sound like that here. Like, I'm gonna
run get pods and it's gonna see connection
not found or something. But we do have
a Kubernetes cluster. There's not a lot going
on in this cluster. In fact, it's pretty
much oh, there's a few things running on
it, but that's not important. There's networking and
there's some storage stuff, but no actual workloads
yet. Yep.
Right.
Nice.
So let's
take a look at this repository. Let me
try and zoom in on this a little
bit so it's still readable.
There's a dark mode now, isn't there? Yes.
There is under settings and Oh, right. Yeah.
It's it's it's pretty good. It's it's great.
I'll play with that later for next thing.
So
this repository
is
considerable by anyone. Right? Anyone can just come
to this repository. It looks like you've documented
it pretty well. And
one of the things that you said when
we're talking about preparation for this episode was
that I could have just used a kind
cluster.
Yep.
I mean, I have access to bare metal.
I decided we're not doing that. So Yeah.
And plus, I think
sorry, Nico. Yeah. The kind cluster might stress
your CPU and ram a bit with all
the workloads and scaling, but it it just
about worked on my last night. So
Yeah. No. I figured if if I threw
a bit more hardware at it, we can
maybe have a bit more fun with the
scaling rules and just see if we can,
like, you know, push it through a little
bit of a speed run maybe. So,
yeah, so feel free to check out this
repository and follow along on your own time.
Now I'm gonna assume, because I like to
make loads of assumptions, is that we should
start with the prerequisites.
Yeah. I mean, it should explain to you
what what we expect to have.
Alright. So Kubectl,
check. Working Kubernetes cluster,
hopefully.
Helm?
Yes. I'm positive I have Helm.
Very good. Okay. Cool. Version three. So
awesome.
And we don't need to create a kind
cluster. So prereqs checked off. Now you've broken
this down into four specific sections. We've got
Yeah. Resource metric scaling, custom metric scaling, external
metric scaling, and then the VPA.
Do you wanna give us a little bit
of flavor on one, two, and three there?
Why they're different and what they mean?
Yep. So
Kubernetes,
as with all of its functionality, sort of
started from the the basic, like,
the auto scaling people were most familiar with.
So that's, like, CPU or memory utilization.
So
allowing you to configure a a target
and say, I want this to
try and make I want to scale this
and try and maintain, like, 70% CPU utilization.
So some sort of sweet spot where you
think you can scale up as more users
start hitting your site, but also you can
scale down and still keep a fairly good
resource utilization so you're not burning money as
you mentioned at the start.
That
that is
a core API. And then over time, people
obviously realize, well, I've got I've got a
lot of workloads that actually that's that's not
the best metric.
The CPU and memory are, you know, either
fairly constant
or they're not coupled to
the metrics that I care about, whether that's
latency or if I know my workloads
my pods can serve a certain number of
requests
per second,
and then that's that's the metric that I
most care about.
So
over time, that cost
effectively, changes were made to the APIs
to
go through something called API aggregation.
The idea being that the API server can
then serve up a number can proxy a
number of different APIs,
and those API paths become metrics dot case
dot I o for resource metrics scaling, so
the original, and custom dot metrics dot case
dot I o for custom metrics,
we'll come back to sort of what the
definition of custom metrics is.
External
dot metrics dot case dot I o for
external metrics, and we'll we'll touch on that
a bit as well. But those those effectively
should cover
all use cases of a metric that you
want to scale a workload on horizontally.
Sweet.
Awesome.
So
let's start with the the resource metrics scaling.
first, make sure we can access the metrics
API.
I mean, can can that fail?
By default, some setups of Kubernetes will come
with nothing installed to serve the metrics API.
So
Yeah. We can find out how your how
your cluster is. Yeah. Metrics server is not
available on my cluster. So this should fail.
Yep. Apparently, that doesn't copy. So
Okay.
Cool.
So that's these commands here. Right? Yep.
Okay. So I mean So these these command
so the second command with the install installation
of the metric server,
and I'm I'm going to update this
later, is you might not need all of
those options. And those options are generally set
up for a kind cluster.
So you're you're using
Kube dot and secure and other bits
to to make it work with a kind
cluster that may not necessarily be
required for all installations.
So this is a cluster API cluster, which
is gonna have a self sane c a.
So I believe we will still need the
Okay.
Awesome. And although I don't like the name
in security or SSN. Yeah. It's incorrect. Because
I think it's those people a bit I
was gonna say really Scottish thing there. I
think that's because I've got your accent in
my ear, but ski west. Like, you know,
it's not insecure. We should we need to
change our vocabulary there, I think.
K. So
preferred address internal IP and secure recovered API
service dot create true.
Alright. I'm just gonna go
for it. What's the worst that can happen?
Let's deploy some metrics over to our cluster,
which starts collecting node based metrics.
Yeah. And that will now be available.
That just might be the pods not there
yet. Is that right? Yeah. Yeah. It takes
it takes about time for the pods to
come up and basically register itself with the
API server saying, I'm I'm here and I'm
serving this API.
I'm assuming that's gonna deploy to the Kube
system namespace.
No.
Maybe in default. By default, I'm not sure.
There we go. Alright.
I guess I I I should have maybe
oh, if I was doing this in production,
I would have tweaked that helm command. So
Yeah.
No metrics available yet. Now this I'm gonna
make some more assumptions as that this is
gonna have some sort of previous ten seconds
script interval
thing. Is that maybe right?
Yes. It does. Okay.
I can't remember exactly what the default script
duration is.
But yeah. It so as you've said, basically,
the metric server is responsible for,
these days, going out and scraping the metrics
endpoints of cubelets. That's why we had to
pass in a cubelet and secure TLS wagon
to get it working with self signed certs.
And that's then responsible for serving up those
metrics
through the API path of metrics.caseio.
And as well as node metrics is also
the one that's responsible for getting plot metrics
through those those same APIs.
Sweet. Well, we now have our top command
working.
Awesome.
So we've got loads of course,
loads of memory. In fact, we're barely tickling
this cluster. Yes.
We can have a better fun with this
for sure. Alright.
Very good.
And that takes the namespace flag. Let's just
see what's gonna why
is copy paste
weird? There we go. Okay. Yeah. So as
you can see, you're you can now correctly
get through the API, like, the CPU memory
usage of different pods.
Alright. So I mean, I don't mean to
put you on the spot here and test
your knowledge, but
this this metric server, I mean, this used
to be built and was this previously the
c adviser stuff that was deprecated and metric
server server replacement for that? So they they
the component
that
the metric server is a replacement for was
something called Heapster. And,
Yep. That was built in and, effectively, had,
like, pluggable back ends so you could I
I think the default
installation option was using mPlugDB as a back
end.
That had some slight problems and shortcomings with
it
in terms of
it if it if certainly
an influx, we experienced a situation where we
managed to fill the influx back end because
we've scaled up our clusters without scaling up
the influx.
It tried, and one of the problems it
had was when you push data into whenever
you created it, it it first pushed data
into the back end before creating it back.
So it didn't have a hold a local
state at all.
So when you created it, if it dropped
your data, it just went, I don't know,
which wasn't wasn't the most fun. So, yeah,
metric server is effectively, like, built from the
ground up for this this very purpose.
Okay. Cool.
I just feel like this command will work
because I haven't closed your repository. Oh, yeah.
Let's
let's copy that. Go back.
It's running.
I don't know why my
I mean I I was expecting something to
go wrong today, but it wasn't copy and
paste. It's always copy. I I don't know
what it is. I just I don't know
how to Mac. Like, I I'm a Linux
user. I'm trying to adapt. It's not going
well ever.
I don't understand why copy and paste is
so difficult. I'm sure it's trivial, and I'm
pressing controls at a command or something. It's
perfect. Yeah. Alright. So we're gonna deploy stress
deploy.
Yeah. And then before I apply it, you
know, I wanna make sure you're not gonna
run a crypto minor on this. So Yep.
This is gonna run program stress.
So we're just gonna be artificially
hammered in the CPU, I guess, a little
bit. Yep.
Memory stress as well.
Alright.
I'll trust you.
One.
Yeah. Stress. Good boy.
And a watch on that. So it's gonna
be pulling down the images and it's just
gonna create some artificial loads. Let's see why
we're doing this. What does it say?
So you want me to run top pods.
We should see them claiming
and then we're going over. Actually, applying our
first HP as well. Shall we take a
look at that? Oh. Yep.
Oh.
There we go. Boom killed.
Is that supposed to happen?
No.
And that may well be because the impeller
seems to be a lot kinder on kind
than it is on
actual clusters.
So
we can we can work around it for
now
by
either we can raise the memory limit or
we can remove the memory limit. I believe
it up to your discretion.
Okay. So
I guess, I don't think I on any
of these episodes, I've ever really spoken about
these resource request limits.
Yeah. Why don't we
collectively put our knowledge together and just talk
about what this is? So Yeah. The resource
request and limits is a way for us
to tell
is it the kubelet that is responsible for
the enforcement of this?
Yes. So the kubelet
the kubelet, I think, is
maybe slightly off here. It pass passing it
down to the container run time, which actually
does some enforcement.
But there's also component of, like, a better
bit that's left to the kubelet. So in
terms of ranking the order and which to
kill pods if resource contention actually happens.
Okay. So we're suggesting here by setting these
resources, and we'll talk about requesting limits in
a second. Yeah. So the cubelet may do
something, but it also may just create the
c groups with the CRI implementation.
Okay. Now
what is 50 m in CPU?
I've been asked this question before and I've
never had a good answer.
It is 50 millicores,
which
there is an internal
piece called the
CFS or completely fair scheduler.
There is a long back story to
some previous issues with the the kernels maths
and how it does. Does it effectively, what
Kubernetes does is by default it has I
think it's a hundred millisecond time slices.
These
these millicores are effectively translated into how much
CPU time in a given bucket
can a pod use of a CPU.
So effectively,
if it was if I was giving it
one full core, aka 1,000 millicores,
I would be saying it can use one
one second sorry, one hundred millisecond the full
one hundred milliseconds of that bucket for a
given CPU core. This is slightly complicated, obviously,
given that in this case, we're definitely running
on a big multi core machine.
So the CFS then comes in and basically
does throttling where if a container
uses more CPU in a given slice than
it should do, it will get throttled for
the next few buckets of time to average
out
so that a single container given a resource
given a CPU request limit can't request limit
can't basically use more CPU than it should
be using.
Oh, sweet. That's a really good explanation. I
think even I understood that and I'm not
the smartest. Okay.
Now this is an on kill. So I'm
gonna assume that this has nothing to do
with our CPU
limits and it's our memory
limits.
Yep.
We'll bump that up. Now do you wanna
what's the difference between a limit and a
request?
So in CPU terms,
effectively, you're saying for for a CPU
request, you're
guaranteeing that on average this pod can use
the equivalent of, in this case,
50 millicores,
so one twentieth,
is my math right, of a CPU on
average over time. In
memory,
you're base
I'm sorry. The limit you're saying,
however,
if there's
spare capacity in the CPU,
you can use up to,
in this case, the equivalent of 75 millicores
of CPU. So if there's contention, if there's
if the pods real sorry. If the node
is really highly utilized, so you've got a
lot of CPU intensive workloads on and all
of them have far higher limits than the
requests. They won't all be able to get
up to their limits,
but they'll still always get their requests. And
it's the request that's used for scheduling the
pods onto the node.
This is still being on killed.
The
other alternative
because in this in the example HPA, we're
only scaling on CPU,
not memory.
The other alternative you can give you have
is not giving it resource
request and limits. This is generally a bad
idea
because
it means that
sched a, the scheduler doesn't really have much
information about how
much resource a given polygism is
likely to use
and that will result in
can result in problems because you get contention.
Okay. Well, they're
happy now.
Why is that not showing me the CPU
memory one?
So it's it's the same thing we we
came came to with first call in that.
It takes a while to for it to
first scrape the Kiplet and discover those the
the metrics for those pods that have been
newly created.
Okay. So we'll get that thirty seconds to
catch up. What we'll do now is
firstly,
because I forgot at the start, if anyone
wants to try Equinix Medal,
then you can use the code Rawkode dash
live at metal.equinix.com.
50 dollars of credit is roughly around a
hundred hours of compute on a smaller instance.
But using the small instance is not very
much fun. So, you know, spend it quicker
and have
and and enjoy it. Now we also have
a comment.
So
some path has asked, does the memory or
can the memory go beyond the limit when
we're running the stress command?
And I think the answer is no. We
just get when it
so when it has the memory limit, the
arm killer is just gonna say, hey, you've
had enough. You're you're barred and kicks out.
Right?
Yes.
So, yeah, you cannot go beyond the memory
limit. And I think based on what guys
said a couple of minutes ago as well
is that you can't
you can go past this CPU limit, but
you'll be throttled on subsequent request to bring
it back under the limit.
Yeah. And and so this this becomes a
problem for, like,
really latency sensitive workloads where if if you're
getting loads of requests fired and respond really
fast,
hit your limit, what if, like, use up
more than your limit within a time window.
And then in the next few windows, you're
you're effectively throttled.
That can cause your latency to spike because
your your
workload's getting throttled, so it's not able to
respond
or do the CPU cycles. It needs to
respond. So you can
you you should be you're able to, like,
lower the window slice to try and combat
that.
You can remove
throttling
completely,
like, the CFS.
Some
some users recommend that.
Generally, it doesn't seem to be recommended for
multi tenant
environments.
So keep that in mind.
Alright. Sweet.
So as we can see here, we actually
needed just under 250
mega RAM for the CPU stress. We needed
almost a gig for the memory stress, but
they both are happy
now. So that's So it's
stressing it's stressing the resources as expected.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm happy with that. Okay. So
what we want to do now
okay. So, yeah, we can see they're hitting
the resource limits.
Now we want to apply a horizontal pod
auto scaler or an HPA
to
make that better. So Yep. Let's have a
look. So that's horizontal pod auto scaler, like,
you know, Will. We'll we'll go version and
a kind of metadata that we expect.
Let's just kinda run through the the specs
side of this and try and try and
understand what's going on. So we'll
come back to scale target ref. I'm assuming
that's just like a label matcher on what
we've got. I guess we're covering it now.
This is gonna say, hey. What is it
we are trying to scale? Is that right?
Yeah. Yeah. So API
version,
so and kind effectively, we're saying it's a
deployment in the apps v one
spec that we've got to scale.
So there's
a number of different
resources
within
Kubernetes that all implement this
behavior called scale,
And that that effectively is what this gets
mapped to behind the scenes.
Sweet.
We then set the minimum and maximum replicas
that we want to accept for this. And
then we define the metrics that we want
to use
as a benchmark for scaling.
Yep. So if I can read this one
correctly, then what we're saying is
if the CPU
of this pod is at 70%
of its CPU
limit,
then it's gonna add on more replicas.
Not quite. So there's there is there
is an an algorithm effectively that the HP
uses.
So
the the HPA, unlike a number of the
other things that signal to scaling owns, that's
that's actually contained within the core Kubernetes controller
manager
code base as a reconciliation
loop.
That's
that's got an algorithm
in it, which effectively each time it's evaluating,
you can configure that on the
controller manager.
It effectively does the maths of scraping
the current metrics or getting the metrics for
the pods currently in the deployment,
getting
effectively what is their current
utilization,
in this case of the CPU resource,
dividing that by the desired, so in this
case, 70,
and then timesing it by the current replicas.
So if we're using a %,
we divide that by 70 so we get
one point or something
that messes off.
Times up by current rep because there's ceiling
on it and then set that as the
new desired rep because
Alright.
Okay. That makes sense. I like it. So
we can just apply this to our cluster.
And
if we take a look at this,
we
can remove those replicas now. Right?
Yes.
I I gave a talk at GET upstairs
about a month ago where actually,
I I I was bold enough to say
that setting replicas and either of these specs
was an anti pattern. And you should just
HPAs in all scenarios even for local dev.
Not sure how well it went down, but
I'm I'm gonna push it. So
what this means is because we have
that is already a way. Right? So
because that CPU thing is always pushing against
the limit, I guess that's what the stress
thing is doing is that right away, this
is when, hey, you probably need more of
these. And that's when it's hard to scale
up. Okay.
So if you and you can also see
that one
of the things you can do is you
can the HPA is quite good at telling
you why it's done a scaling action. So
you can do kubectl describe
HPA.
Okay. Set the size of our replica set
to three because the CPU resource utilization percentage
of request went above a target.
Yeah.
Yeah. Cool. And you can see higher
up, you've got the metric section as well
with the current and the target.
Sweet.
And then we delete.
So that's it. That's that's That's that's resource
spectrum scale.
So you can also we we set this
up to scale on CPU. You can also
do resource
utilization scaling on memory as well.
Okay. And
as a a rule of thumb or a
guide for anyone that wants to start using
this, is this the is this the first
place you would start for workloads?
Yeah. I I think it's the unless you're
coming into it with
a real knowledge of, like, what the what
the metric that's most important for you is,
I think this is this is certainly the
easiest to set up. Like, the metric server
is
owned and supported by a core a core
part of the Kubernetes community
second instrumentation.
And it's it's it's well tested.
So this setting up
the metric server and setting up resource
scaling is really easy as you've seen. It's
like, in this case,
one help chart to set up the metro
server and then a a couple of
bare YAML
objects.
Okay. Definitely.
Alright. Plus they don't have to re instrument
their own application if there's not added premium
fees metrics or anything like that. Yeah. Yeah.
So it's yeah. I'd say it's a good
time point too.
Alright. Let's take a look at custom metric
scaling.
Yeah.
What are custom metric?
So
custom metrics
are
metrics which correspond
to a Kubernetes object. So they're not just
any arbitrary object,
like,
whether external
to the cluster, so something like QN potentially.
They are either metrics that are exposed
by each pod in a, say, a deployment
or
potentially on other Kubernetes
objects. So
ingress objects are one example. So, effectively, if
you were deploying a service
scaling behind an ingress object,
you can make use of metrics produced by
that ingress object as well as a custom
metric.
Alright.
So for this then, we need to deploy
Prometheus.
Yep.
Do I really need to put forward?
That that is just to have a check
if we
were if if if you were unsure about
whether it's
set up correctly. But
Okay.
So helm install.
Alright.
Let's see what we got here.
Right. So we got
a node exporter,
a cube state metrics,
push gateway in the server, and alert manager.
So with the previous server is obviously the
database. We've got the alert manager for doing
alerts. Why are those pending?
Not like pending.
Yeah.
Oh, they requested yes.
There should be a way to disable that,
surely.
So the problem is this cluster is not
really configured
for
storage classes and PVC.
So
let's
let's let's fix that first.
Let's go over here. Let's grab this helm
chart. I'm sure we can tell it to
use a host path. In fact, can edit
it. Let's just do that.
Edit, deploy,
Prometheus server. Is it a staple set or
deploy?
You can disable the persistent volumes.
Well, that's easier. Is that just a helm
flag I can drop in?
Yep.
So
if we go helm upgrade
Yeah. What's the last what's the last values
flag? Do you remember?
Agreed.
Reuse values. Okay. So helm upgrade,
reuse values,
Prometheus
set. What do you know there?
So there's
to direct. It
is
oh, come on. There's a lot of options
in this chart.
Are you sure you don't want me just
to edit the deployment? Yeah. Might might be
easier to.
Alright. Let's see.
So
I meant okay. It looks fine.
Oilment.
Okay. We got data here.
Thing.
Let's step back here. Yeah. We we don't
really need alert manager. No. No. We don't
in this case. So
Oh.
Alright. They're gonna make me create that path
first. Is that the problem?
Oh, this error wasn't there. Wasn't there. Yeah.
See.
Alright. Come on here. Log dash f. Copy.
Oh, it's 9 anyway. Oh, it's the other
one.
Let's see. Prometheus server
and
unable to create
Open permissions to that. So I have find
the the command
the the flag you want. It is
server.
Use values.
Prometheus
set server.
Dot
persistent volume dot enabled
equals false
Capital e.
Okay.
Oh, yeah. In the chart.
Oh, yeah.
In the
Prometheus community.
So that's Prometheus.
Should have used Cane.
It's I'm taking notes for things that I
need to fix for people not using kind
to get.
Alright. Container crane. So it's it's got
no persistence, no PVC, our crash with backup
will disappear now that that's running.
And this say terminating.
It'll go away eventually. Right? We have what
we need. That's important. Yep. Okay.
So let's do the port forward. Make sure
we can browse to it. Make sure everything's
happy.
Post 1990.
And we have a Prometheus.
Now because those node exports are running, we
should have
yeah. We'll bunch of status. So
Yep.
Desk. Perfect.
Cool.
Alright.
Okay. That then? Yep. So it's called the
port forward and go back to this tutorial.
So now we're going to deploy our sample
application.
Let's take a look at our YAML.
Sample deploy.
So this is
running
some auto scale demo thing.
Got Prometheus annotations.
So that's gonna be scraped by Prometheus
and more resource limits. Oh, and even a
service now.
Yep.
Does it need to hard code the cluster
IP?
No.
I don't even know
if my I don't think 10 or even
my not even my service side or so.
Okay.
So
let's deploy.
Yeah. Let's deploy that. Okay. So we're gonna
apply Kubernetes scaling to
sample
deploy.
We'll
get the service.
IP,
good. Yep. 172 is what I needed.
We'll make sure we got an endpoint.
It looks healthy.
So
you want the port forward to Prometheus again,
and we're gonna take a look at the
HTTP request total.
Now depending
on the previous script interval,
we may just have to kill a little
bit of time. We lowered that as part
of the install to thirty seconds.
Lower that to thirty. I would have lowered
it to four.
H t p. There we go.
And let's just graph it
over.
We don't even have a minute yet.
Is that alright?
You need an aggregator on it as well
to Right.
But yeah. So you need you need multiple
different things for that anyway. But
we're get we're getting the main tracking. Yeah.
Yeah. Are.
Here we go. So we can see the
values too.
Yeah. So we just we have a couple
of comments. So I can just lose a
few seconds so we can maybe graph it
as well.
Never seen a hard coded service IP before.
Yeah. I I I'll blame Guy for being
a bit silly with that cluster IP. I'm
not sure what you were thinking there. That's
something. I I have no idea. I I
suspect that was me. Yeah. It's at 11:30
on Monday night. But yeah. That seems like
a good idea. Right?
Works your kind. It must work everywhere.
So that's raised from two to three.
Is the sample application going to be degrading
over time? Is that This this sample application
is recording
all requests made to it,
which includes
effectively health checks. That's
But the http
oh, okay. This is request or this is
not the response time. No. Okay. Gotcha. So,
yeah, that's gonna up to four.
Yeah. So it's an ever ever increment time.
I've got it. Okay. Cool. I mean, it
took me a minute, but I got there.
Okay.
So now
we have to install something else.
Oh, we can visit the app.
Oh, we don't need to do that, do
we? Yeah. Okay. We don't need to do
that. No. It's it's it's fairly simple. Like,
it just shows I've served x number of
requests
all time.
Alright. Why not then?
Eighty eighty eighty eighty.
Eight. 10.
I'll go for a nice round 100.
So now
we need to install the Mepheus adapter. So
is that the part that is gonna allow
us to use custom metrics then as part
of our HPA rules? Yeah.
So if you run
so to start to show this, you can
do
you can run against the
cluster
kubectl
get API services.
Interesting.
It might be APIservices.a
you might have to fully qualify it. APIservices.API
registrations.
There we go. There is no dash.
Okay.
Cool. So what you can see here is
all the metrics
that that cluster knows about,
where the service it should send it to
is, whether it's available and how old it
is. So
you can see that we've already installed v
one bit one dot metrics. Okay. So IO
being served by the the metrics server.
Custom metrics is a different API path
served by a different component,
so we need to set up effectively something
that is going to register itself against the
API server saying, if you receive a request
that matches this API path, don't don't try
and serve it yourself. Instead, send it on
to me. I will send you data back
in the format you expect.
Cool. Alright. Well, let's get that enabled then.
Hopefully, that doesn't need a PVC.
Oh, yeah.
K.
One one thing that's probably worth mentioning here
is so we're using the Prometheus adapter for
this example.
That
isn't the only option for setting up custom
metrics. There's there's a number of other implementations.
So Lando have got one called
Kube Metrics Adapter, I think, which has a
load of functionality.
There's there's others that have been built by
other companies
and communities
as well.
Cool.
Is there a Google Sheets adapter?
I think the closest you can get is
Snapdriver.
And also one other thing, which I think
a lot of people obviously come across this
and go, oh, that's that's cool. There's multiple
different adapters that can do different things. I
could maybe get
both install
multiple of them and that way have functionality
of that one plus the Prometheus adapter plus
so I could use data dot metrics and
Prometheus adapter.
Unfortunately, at the moment, one of the limitations
of these API aggregations is you can only
have one thing registering itself as saying I
serve these metrics.
There's not
there's there's some discussion at the moment to
build effectively a proxy
that would say
would say
say for this namespace, this component serves metric
that serves custom metrics and this namespace that
other component. But the moment is you've got
to choose one of the solutions.
Yes. So the problem being if we take
a look at the API services then, is
that only one adapter can register as a
custom metric provider? Yes. If you have metrics
and
and Fox DB and Prometheus, you really need
to pick one for these use cases. Yeah.
Alright. I'm as and I'm assuming the thing
you were talking about there would just be,
like, a gateway that registers this and then
proxies them onto to different Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
That's kind of the discussion
as a kid. But
Alright. And then if we hit the endpoint,
we have our
these all are custom metrics?
Yep. From us. Yeah.
So if I grab this for HTTP
oh, nice.
And so this is this is where it
gets interesting. So the Prometheus adapter
but Prometheus metrics are not
PromQL is not what the API server speaks.
So it's sending metrics to a certain API
path and expects a response back in a
certain format.
So Prometheus adapter is about sitting in the
middle there and you're configuring it as to
how
you want to what metrics you want to
get out of Prometheus and what metrics how
you transform them into the format that
the API server expects.
So you can see one of the things
you can see here is that
this name, pods slash h t p request
per second, that's not the name of the
metric in
Prometheus.
We've been looking at a a
metric that is supposed by the app called
h t p request total.
Yeah.
So
do you want to jump to the file
that we used when we installed the Prometheus
adapter?
So we did a bit of as part
of the the command that that we placed
then with some configuration.
This one here. There we go. So
here you can see we're doing some overriding
of the default, like, Prometheus endpoint is sitting
on to match up with Prometheus chart.
And then we've got these rules.
So
for this is Prometheus adapters configuration language. So
here we're saying, serve up some custom metrics
rules under these
these
queries.
So in this case, we're saying
any query
that matches each field request total,
which doesn't have the Kubernetes namespace blank and
doesn't have the Kubernetes pod name blank, that's
not so important for this this
sort of thing. But in case you're wanting
to stop
potentially
exposing
metrics from, like,
POS containers.
And then we're saying
if we come back to resources,
we're saying if the name matches
regex
dot
underscore total,
Alright.
Yeah. Perform this metrics query
on
the series.
So
do a sum rate
of the series that you have found
with the same label matchers.
And in this case, we're doing the time
window of the rate is two minutes.
So effectively, what are the requests per second
of this
metric over the last two minutes,
same group values, and then so all these
things that are in, like,
double double angled brackets,
they're effectively part of the Prometheus adapter's
query language.
Got it. So you can you can have
a look at the Prometheus adapter documentation
for certain more detail on how these work.
But then present
that
metric as
this metric. You can see we've got a
a regex in the matches.
We're then using that
group that we've captured as part of the
presentation of the metrics. So that's where that
that's how that transformation from a speed request
total
to a speed request per second comes in.
Alright. That's nice.
So
or we can actually just request that metric
then. Right? Yep.
K. Let's see that.
Alright. That's nice.
And
as as back with the CPU,
it uses Kubernetes internal presentation
of numbers. So that's why it's it's had
an average of 33
milli requests per second over the last two
minutes.
Rather than
presenting us, like, zero point zero zero or
something, it presents us 33, at least. Yeah.
Of course. Why not? Okay.
Alright. So now we're gonna use
an HPA like we did with the first
example
to scale on our custom metric,
and then you provided another
deployment, I I assume, that is gonna generate
a load to increase those number of requests
per millisecond. Yeah.
Yeah. It's in this case, it's a job
because that way, we can see it scaling
down again. But
Alright. So we got our HPA. It looks
very much like the last one.
Okay.
So the metrics type here has changed from
resource
to pods.
Why would that not be custom?
So under
custom metrics, there's two different metrics types. There's
the pods, which is a metric that's exposed
by every pod in the scale target,
or there's objects. So that's
things like ingress objects.
So effectively that in that case, you're saying
this is a metric that comes from a
single object that maps to
the pods in the scale target.
But that that changes basically how it does
the evaluation of the maths behind the scenes.
Alright. Okay. Okay. I got you. So
So in this case, we got more than
one pod. So it's gonna have to actually
calculate that across rather than on an individual
pod basis. Okay. That makes sense.
Oh, I never I never knew that. That's
really useful.
Okay. So let's deploy this then.
We'll just copy the
password different. Okay.
Apply
case to we want a sample h p
a followed by load.
We now have a horizontal pod out of
scaler. Now we wanna generate some load.
Let's run get pods, see what's going on.
Our load generator is spinning up.
And
we can monitor
this.
Cool. So this is gonna because you've got
the dash w there, it's gonna watch this.
And what we should see is the number
of record number of replicas claim
after thirty seconds, I guess, because that's the
premium script interval.
Start claiming towards max pods.
Yeah. So you could you could see we've
generated load.
Suddenly, target is way above sorry. The current
utilization is way above the target. I each
the pods on average within that deployment have
each received
93.2
requests per second over the last two minutes
instead of
the target
0.5.
So it's it's scaling up.
Yeah. And we can see that this that's
based on a measurement how much
how
far beyond the target we are. It's actually
hey, we are gonna need more than one
of these. We're actually gonna scale by three
and then it's added on another four because
yeah. Correct.
Yeah. Cool.
We have a a question from Sam Path
again. So you've asked what is the difference
between horizontal scaling and vertical scaling?
I mean, we can tackle that now. We're
also I guess, we're about to show the
v p a?
We've got I mean, it depends how long
we got. But we've got external metrics as
well. And so
in this case, we're we're horizontally scaling and
each new
pod that we're creating here
is is being spun up with exactly the
same resource
requests and limits as the previous pods in
the deployment. So nothing is modifying,
like, how much CPU and memory each pod
gets. They each get the same that we
defined right at the start when we went
kubectl apply deploy.
Yaml.
With vertical pod auto scaling
instead,
I mean, we'll we'll show in more detail
later, the resources get adjusted in those pods
to allow them to scale up and down
to maintain
utilization
within each pod rather than
so much across the deployment on average.
Yeah. Horizontal scaling,
add more instances. Vertical scaling, get the instance
more power. That's the simple way. I mean,
yours was much more correct, but I just
saw it summarize as well.
Okay. So with that higher max, we've got
10.
HP is working well with the custom metrics,
especially from Prometheus. Really, really cool demo. I
like that.
So much, I'm gonna delete it now.
That was
k.
Alright.
Yeah. That's just a fail of it. Didn't
really that's the value fail. Okay. Yeah. We
can ignore that.
Alright.
So
we have another question. I'll come back to
that in a second. Let's get any setup
we need done for external metrics.
So
you kinda covered us what we were describing
custom metrics. So
we got resource metrics which come
from the the node on a cluster. We
got a custom metrics which are exposed or
metrics that we can associate with Kubernetes objects.
And then external metrics could be anything that
we want. Okay. Yes. It could it could
be pulling
how many domains and and dd146.com
or whatever. Right? Like, it could be just
Yep. That was a horrible example, but the
first thing I my head. It could be
any arbitrary information. We could just have it
count the number of tweets on my profile
in the last hour or something. Right.
That was a slightly better example of the
the terrible.
And
to do this,
what you want to do based on what
I see here is we're gonna deploy RabbitMQ
and then start throwing messages at a topic
and then use that as a skill factor.
Yeah.
Awesome. Alright. Let's get this running then.
Is rabbit m q gonna try and get
persistence?
We are doing it. I wouldn't want to
stay.
Ending.
Alright. Let's that's a staple set this time.
Alright. Robert.
And
claim. Oh, it's got template and and everything.
Alright. Let's pull up the chart.
That's annoying. Okay. The
colon q exclamation mark doesn't shut down everything.
Anyway,
this chart was okay. So it's a bit
nami the bit nami charts are a pain.
Because I could never find the example values
then.
Persistence
enabled
persistence dot enabled equals false, I think, should
do it.
Alright.
So
alright.
Upgrade.
RabbitMQ.
Reuse values.
Set okay. One more time, please.
Persistence
dot enabled equals false. Okay. Alright. Okay.
Alright. Let's give that a second. Couple more
questions,
comments. So Andrea says, super interesting topic. What's
your take on AWS Carpenter?
Do you wanna go first or second?
I I I will go second.
I
think AWS Carpenter is
firstly, really good and amazing.
What I find frustrating is the fact that
we tried to do no doubt was scaling
based on unschedulable
pods.
I think that was a
I mean, it's not wrong.
Worked for a while, but you know, using
actual metrics and calculating your applications health and
let's say and understanding or using all these
other metrics to do node auto scaling. I
think it's a much wiser solution. So I'm
really excited to see that come out.
K? Yeah. I I I agree. I think
I agree for the most part.
And I think,
like, there's there's there are historical reasons why
the cluster autoscaler,
which is owned by, like, auto scaling, uses
pending pods as its signal.
And there are I mean, there's there's, like,
there are shortcomings to it, obviously. Like, there's
there's the fact that you can't really have
much headroom aside from using, like, hacking peanuts
pods to, like with the that are low
priority and get chucked away when high priority
pods scale.
I'm
I'm really interested in, like, the the design
of it and how they're potentially aiming to
basically be able to scale anything,
any anything which has a scale target
implementation.
That
that sounds like it's got a lot of
promise
for us at Skyscanner, but the ability to
scale on any arbitrary CloudWatch metrics and metric
would be cool.
I'm yeah. I'm I'm I'm
having some conversations with the web maintainers. They've
got office hours
starting
from January on
Tuesday
evenings UK
well, European time.
Sort of morning, separate time.
I would encourage anyone who's interested to
come on and have a chat.
Yeah. So,
I mean, now that you've been a bit
more
a bit more conservative in your answer. Like,
I I don't think that it was wrong.
Like, we should never have done that approach.
I just mean that, you know, waiting until
something that's actually unscheduled before scaling can be
optimized. Like, we can try to use measures
to protect when and, you know, we don't
we we don't wanna failure. It depends how
quickly or how slow it is to add
those new notes to the note code. And
if that takes five minutes and we're waiting
till something is unschedulable,
you're talking potentially ten minutes before
you're in a position. And that makes me
uncomfortable. So I Yeah. That's I'm actually cool.
And I'm looking forward to seeing that and
adopt it and hopefully adapt it to other
cloud providers too.
Alright.
That persistence thing
did not help, unfortunately. Yeah.
Even though the flag does seem to be
correct,
we still have a persistent volume claim.
The volume mode is failed system.
That did not work.
Alright. That's oh, okay. I just need to
try and hack at it.
Sorry about this.
Oh, no. It's I I should give you
a fully working cluster instead. I don't I
cut corners. So
it was easier for me. Alright.
So where's this volume?
What was that called before I delete it?
Data. Okay.
So that's not the volume I need.
Volume notes here.
Yep. Name data.
Where's our volumes?
So
name,
beta.
If we can get this working this time,
temp,
rabbit.
I mean, that shouldn't have a permissions issue.
It's gonna be trust be that the directory
doesn't exist, isn't it? I think so. Yeah.
So
let's just do that.
And then I'll work out what they'll notice
on, and I'll SSHN.
It's
And create. Correct?
Oh, no. It did not it did not
like that.
Because updates are okay.
So is it maybe that we just tried
to update something that it
don't know how we should handle that. Right?
Let's try one more time.
Back.
Now let's just make sure that's just doing
what we expect. So if we did disable
persistence,
does it stop the PVC being created?
That's probably important.
Stateful set dot nano.
Yep.
That's it. And the container,
Volumes.
Okay. So yeah. We use an empty there
and it will not create anything.
So that should
it should be okay. Let's just assume it
was some
some issue.
There's my there's my way of clear. There's
some issue,
and we're not reusing the values this time.
Did you give me a values fail?
No.
So it's just all the default? Fair. Yeah.
Alright.
Let's see.
And we have another comment from Justin.
Nice example. Yeah. Well, I mean, it would
be a nice example, wouldn't it? Yeah. We'll
try it. We'll try.
There we go. Alright. So they have more
great than the handle
disabling the persistence.
Less than slack.
Yeah. So this is fun. I like it
when things go wrong.
Just because you you kinda get to challenge
some of the assumptions you made, and then
I think, hopefully, that's useful to some people.
So, you know, we'll see. Yep. Alright. So
we now have a rabbit in queue, then
we want to deploy publisher
to this. So let me fix my pass.
This is case three.
And we
are going to upgrade our adapter
with our new values fail.
Yep.
Have you tested the Hemopgrade on this?
Yes.
Yes. That's one I got.
Alright. Prometheus.
K. So now we have to wait.
Well, that collects some more metrics. What we
should see from our API services then is
that we have something new registered for custom
external
metrics. There
we go. Yep.
Field discovery check. I'm assuming
it's just not healthy yet since they haven't
updated. I
guess not. It's probably done the registration
and then not not updated itself and said
I'm serving these. Yeah. That's only thirty seconds.
That's not Yeah. It's not part of the
readiness appropriate. So let's give that at least
a faint chance. There we go.
And grab for external.
Much better. There we go. That looks good.
We now have
external metrics.
And what we're gonna do is take a
look at the value of our rabbit and
cure.
Yeah.
Not available yet. So that now may just
be the thirty second delay from the previous
script interval.
And it'll also there's also then another lag
introduced because, effectively, the the way the Prometheus
adapter works is it's rather than doing ad
hoc queries when you create it. It's instead
doing discovery
of the series against the Prometheus
and telling the API server, these are the
ones I know about. You can create a
need for this.
Oh, you got a joke or something?
Okay.
So let's let's make sure I because I
I don't think I understood everything you said
there. Okay. So we upgraded the Prometheus adapter.
Let's take a look at the values that
we've we've modified there then. Let's see what's
changed. So
style of the Prometheus thing. Okay. We've added
our extra.
Yeah. That's the old one. Right? Yeah. Yeah.
That's exactly the same as the old one.
Okay. And then so we've added this new
external section,
which has got a new series
for hand okay. So this is just fetching
queue lamp size and messages.
Yeah.
We're seeing this applies to
I don't wanna guess. Why don't you you
walk through this? So
one one of the things that I mentioned
before
is that
the Kubernetes
API server is making these requests at at
sorry. The API originally
is making these requests through the API and
then again, proxy. They're made in a really
specific pattern.
So if you jump back to the the
query that wasn't working, I guess, the the
kubectl get raw.
You can see
we'll figure it Why that's not working? You
can see that it's making this call to
external.metrics.hsio,
then an API version.
That's fine. And then namespaces,
then a namespace name, and then
the metric.
So if we then
jump back to the
written up config,
what we're saying here is that this series
actually has a label
called Kubernetes
namespace.
So if you scroll a bit further right.
Yeah. So we've got a label on this
metric called Kubernetes namespace.
And what we need to do is map
that into
make sure that that
metric is served up under the path that
Kubernetes is creating on. So in this case,
we're saying use the value
of the label Kubernetes namespace, and actually that
becomes the resource
namespace
label
when the HPA is querying for it. There's
also
if it was a pod specific metric, you
might also need to or you might want
to basically use the value of a different
label as the pod
metric. So when we were doing the custom
metrics
example,
you can you can actually query for a
specific pods
use of
value for a metric. So you can basically
map that label value into, say, this is
the pod name even even if it's some
weird label because of the way you're exposing
it somehow.
Cool. Okay.
So
we probably wanna work out
this. Yep.
First things first, let's see if the metric
is getting into
Prometheus.
I thought the same.
Great. Thanks.
Oh, yours is great. Mine is alright.
I wouldn't say that. I just I'm just
yeah. We were put forward into service before
the time.
And it's still here. So let's refresh. And
what we wanna see is do we have
oh, we do not. Nope. So let's jump
to the status targets
on the Prometheus.
Okay.
Does it even know about the targets?
So if you search for rabbit
It is
deadline exceeded.
Alright. Let let's try that then. So
let's get pods.
Port forward.
Grab it. What port was that on?
9419.
Okay. No.
No. It doesn't look healthy. Okay. Oh, well,
yeah. That's just actually so it does say
running. Right? Yeah. Okay. Let's take a look.
Is
that port number correct?
1439?
Red name. Oh,
wait. Something this is an error message.
Readiness probe.
Unable to oh.
Might this be
how how how good is the headless service
support in?
Yeah. It should work. Let's let's check.
We've got endpoints.
Yeah. That looks okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's describe
pods. We'll try a couple of things. We
can always jump on to the VPA and
come back down. So
what is this actually telling us?
So it's trying to speak
to
okay. So the actually, the service name is
supposed to be RabbitMQ headless.
So looks good. Okay. Yeah.
It's got endpoints.
I mean, both those services actually look headless.
But
okay.
Let's see. Node rabbit not running at all.
Nothing.
So
suggestion start the node.
I mean,
the we we fax everything as to delete
the pod. Right?
For for if we if we had to
look at the full logs or are those
Oh, we don't even look at the logs
now. Now.
Looks good.
Yeah.
Are those events old?
Where's the probes?
Did we did we make mistake of of
trying to upgrade rather than reinstalling from scratch?
Again I I it. Okay. Those are answer
old. I think it is healthy now.
And yet?
I don't know.
Take a look at this. What do we
got? Where's the ports?
Alright.
Nine four one nine is the metrics.
K.
Let's put forward
in four one nine.
I'm not I'm not making a mistake there.
Like, that's right. Isn't it? Nine four Yeah.
Nine four one nine
metrics.
I'm gonna delete the pod, and then we'll
see if those events disappear. And then we'll
come we'll do the VPA, and then depending
on how we're looking for time, we may
look back. So Yep.
And I'm sure if you and if you
wanna try this in your own time, it
it works in kind and potentially
something to do with the changes we're making
live. So we'll see.
I mean, it wouldn't it wouldn't be the
live demo without something failing properly hard.
Maybe better now.
Let's try that again.
The response is probably better.
Yeah.
Eric. That is not healthy. Yeah.
Bugs
starting.
K.
Last chance, rabbit. Come on.
You can have used gnats. No?
I've
I thought Rabbit was the easy price.
I've never really had much problems with Rabbit
in the past, to be fair. So
alright. Let's go on to the VP. We'll
come back to Rabbit. Okay. Yeah. Alright.
Okay. So let's see what we got over
here then.
Good comment there from Justin. Because we have
disabled persistent storage, it may struggle to initialize
the second time. I mean, they should start
from fresh, I hope.
But we'll definitely
try that. I may try him on install
and reinstall when we come back.
In fact, I'll just check one.
Should we delete it and then come back
to it? Or while Let us
delete and then come back to it. Alright.
Alright.
So persistence disabled.
Let's just leave that while we do the
VPN. K. Yeah.
So vertical part of scaling as we kinda
we just said to people horizontal means add
more of the thing. The vertical part of
scaling just means tweak those resource limits
that we have on our
objects.
Yeah.
We're using cowboys sis what's cowboys sis up?
It is I can't remember what who they're
tied to. It's a it's a set of
quite useful charts.
You can have a look at them on
our top so that there is some security
scanning, etcetera.
Alright. So we add that. We're gonna deploy
stress deploy from example four.
Stress
deploy.
And we'll we'll probably need to up the
memory again because this is a familiar one.
Alright. Okay.
Oh, it's okay. I don't know if that's
a auto scaler. I love that everything is
just going to this default in space.
Yeah. On Cal. Okay. So
it's
b p a.
Alright.
So what was it we said we needed
here? It was
I
I think it was, like, 270
gigs in that it said 270 megs, sorry,
in that one.
It was one gig time here.
One gig or so.
Okay.
Let's reapply
and deploy.
Any labels on these just to make it
feel or not a bit easier?
There's an app on.
Yeah.
Okay.
I may have
may have increased the the memory scaling on
that one from the previous example.
Let's go with
Yeah. It's happy. Okay. Cool.
And just check the CPU one as well.
Okay.
So let's bump that up. In fact, that'll
probably just be the CPU here one thing.
We actually we did bump that up in
the last one too.
But I don't wanna break your your actual
scaling of that. Yeah. We we can tweak
as we need. Yeah.
And that's now healthy.
Oh, it was healthy. Mhmm.
The on
Two. I don't know why I'm being so
specific with those numbers, but
and creating running
all code.
Let's let's start. Okay.
Cool. We did this. Let's actually see let's
try and get those limits down to close
so the VPA can actually do stuff, I
guess. Right? Yeah.
That would still be better.
So our CPU,
why was that being on kill just using
three meg?
I think I might have just been, like,
grabbing it before the poll it's like, once
the poll Oh, right. Started up. But, no,
I actually started going, I'm here to stress
your stuff.
Right. Right. Of course. I keep forgetting about
that delay. Right. So we we need 1,100
meg on memory and 80 on the CPU.
So let's do that first.
So we'll say request
memory.
1,100. So we know that's the baseline.
So the request will be our baseline.
Yep. And then we're gonna set some limits.
So we'll say 112
because we're being really stingy. So
we're not really giving it much wiggle room
there. Yeah. Now let's see if our CPU
run.
And there we go. Okay. So we want
meg cores and 30 meg.
So
800.
That's that's speaking on them. That's actually been
throttled right now. Yeah.
I cannot remember basic numbers.
Okay.
Folks say, yeah, you can have up you
can stretch to a thousand and we're only
gonna give you 42 here. But that's it.
Pretty finely tuned, I guess.
Yeah. Pretty pretty finely tuned, like bumping up
against those limits.
If we grab on stress, I should just
return those two. There we go. Okay.
Oh, no.
They're both being killed.
I think it might it might be one
of those ones where they're actually, like, bumping
up and down with the memory and depending
on when you get it, it's
potentially a useful met a metric or not.
Oh, alright.
Yes. Guess we can tweak the b p
a anyway. So Yeah.
And 50 should cover everything.
And let's just see. We know what didn't
really go much bigger than that. So Sure.
K.
Oh, that's the old one. Okay. Yep.
Running and running.
Do not touch anything.
Nope. Memory's dead. No.
Let's just start speaking of numbers at Lakes.
Okay.
Oh, I've got the w. I was wondering
why that wasn't actually doing the watch, and
it's because of the
alright. Okay. Running. Running. No arm kills. The
CPU
stress one that's
running is the older one, though.
So it is alright. Let's bump up the
CPU one.
So I guess it's eating a bit more
memory than I thought.
I'm so confident I'm not gonna have to
tweak that again. I'm just gonna go to
the next step.
Okay.
So let's take a look at our VPA.
VPA.
Alright. You wanna run us through this?
So yeah. This is
so you can see this is, like, under
an API version auto scaling dot case dot
kind of record auto scaler. So this is
a custom resource definition.
Some people may be familiar with them, some
may not.
But this this basically is
an extension of the the base Kubernetes APIs
with a new custom resource,
and this is this is effectively declaring an
instance. So that means you can then interact
with it using kubectl.
And this custom resource
these custom resources, sorry, are picked up by
the vertical pod autoscaler and used to inform
it
about what behaviour we want.
And it also writes back
status
to these custom resources so that we can
basically have a look at what it's saying
about
what behaviour it intends to undertake.
So in this case, we give it some
metadata, a name,
usual thing, we expect that. And then as
with the HKs before, we're giving a spec,
so a target ref. In this case, we're
pointing it at the CPU stress app.
Then
this is this is where the magic of
the VPA comes in. We're giving it a
resource policy.
So
we're gonna need to tweak this because we've
had to throw up the resources.
So that's that was gonna be my first
question. It's like, right now, we have both
of these running, but we actually we, you
know, we we bumped them a little bit
higher than we wanted.
Yeah. Could we I I
don't know how the VP works specifically. If
we just put this back down so they're
both on killing and apply the VP, will
it fix it?
It can potentially run into issues.
So the problem is it it's it's pulling
it's pulling its data
from
the metrics API. So depend if if these
things are repeatedly on killing and
therefore the metrics API is giving a misleading
idea of how much resources these pods are
using, it might not be able to do
the maths it needs to do to figure
out, oh, wait. That needs more CPU or
memory.
Okay. So
this best test CPU thing on the stress
program, does that mean consume four CPUs?
It means run it on four threads.
Right. Okay.
If we've got this at fifteen hundred and
five hundred and we go to our VPA,
does that mean that we want this
at a minimum I mean, the minimum probably
has to match. Right? Yes.
In this case. 500
m
and 1,500 m I. And then we can
say down here, you can have four whole
course and three GI.
Yeah.
And that should work for the memory and
the CPU. It'll be only targeting the CPU
one, but this In this case, we're only
targeting the CPU. Okay. And and we can
also basically tell it, actually, only monitor and
modify. And so
for instance, if you're running a Java app
where it may be
always appearing like it's using all of the
heap, therefore, the memory utilizations
to Kubernetes
always looks really high. You may only want
the VPA to monitor the CPU and never
to modify the memory.
Okay. Cool.
So
I just apply that. Is it gonna do
anything?
So
if you apply that and then we can
have a look at the logs of the
vertical pod one of the vertical pod autoscalers
components.
Right.
There's no events. That means it's not doing
anything yet. Right?
Not yet. And that's because, again, we've gotta
wait for a previous and all those metrics
to to do something.
I
I sorry. I tell a lie. It is
already picked up. So if you jump back,
So you can see that it's got these
conditions,
status conditions.
So status is true and it's provided a
recommendation.
And you can see below that the recommendation.
Okay. So we have
what's the lower bound here in this context?
So the the lower bound is you
I'm trying to remember exactly the
the math.
The lower bound is how much
Is it this?
No. It's how much it's used.
I
can't remember exactly. Alright.
So what does this recommendations
suggesting right now? Because I I'm I'm not
sure, Andrew. Is it telling it to increase
it? Is it telling it
So
if you
so if you scroll up a bit
again
so there's there's basically
there's
the update policy, update mode. And so VPA
has
a number of modes it can operate in.
So there's
auto
recreate,
Currently, two are the same,
which basically says
when you're
when you do this, recreate
the pods to change the
the
change change the resource
stuff. So basically, it says if you think
that we need to change the resource request
on this, delete it, like, remove an existing
pod to trigger recreation of the pod with
the new recommendations.
There's
initial, which basically says, like, if a pod
has been assigned resources,
never delete it to force recreation of that
and give it new resources. The reason auto
and recreate are different is because
auto,
in the future, will hopefully be able to
do in place updates with resources on pods,
and therefore, be the the recommended way because
it's the least disruptive.
And then there's also off, which basically allows
you to if you're unsure about the VPA
and how it might affect your workloads, you
can basically install the VPA,
say, watch these workloads and, like, record your
recommendations,
but don't actually do anything about them.
Alright.
So that's what the recommender's doing. There's then
other components
in it.
So there's the
updater.
So check that then takes the recommendations produced
by the recommender,
checks
whether the managed pods being monitored by that
VPA CRD
are have the correct resources set. And if
not, it kills them so it can be
recreated by their controllers.
So the DPA doesn't actually operate on. It
doesn't change anything in the deployment that is
it's monitoring in this space. It's it instead
has
the the third and final component at admission
plugin actually make changes to the pods when
they're created. So, effectively, the API server, the
deployment in this case goes
if a pod's been deleted by the VPA
goes, well, that's been deleted. I need to
create a new pod to match my desired
account.
Create a create a new pod, and that
the API server passes it through the admission
plugin, which takes the recommendation,
pulls that and sets the resources.
Ah, okay.
Alright. So
this so you're suggesting we can take a
look at the logs from the recommender?
Yep.
Home event will be discarded because it's too
old.
Alright. Yeah. I think that's unrelated, isn't it?
I think that's what we were talking about
the the thing.
Then we did the describe, we just did.
So now
we can
scale this up.
Sure. But I'm looking for here.
So if you do have a look at
the if you describe the pods that match
the label selector,
Describe pods dash l app equals CPU stress
up.
Yep.
Oh, I bumped the limit up.
Oh, yeah.
Because our limit was
1,500, and it's now decided you probably want
this as 1,700.
Phew.
Alright. That's the end of the v p
one. Nice. Okay.
A moment of truth.
Where's rabbit?
It's running as to hop on restart.
Let's see.
I think I'm getting metrics.
No. Doesn't look
too happy.
Put forward service.
Correct me for this.
K.
And
if it works no. Okay. We don't have
No. No. Never mind. No big deal. Yep.
Cool. Awesome.
Let me pop that off. So if anyone
has any questions, we're gonna finish up in
just a few moments so you can get
them in now and we'll do our best
to tackle them.
I think thank you, guy, for putting all
that together and, like, you know,
just given this that kind of running commentary
as well and explaining all those concepts and
the vocabulary.
You know, I think
using the HP and the VPA is is
really important when adopting Kubernetes. And it's it's
just nice to have an example like this
where we can set and go through it
from start to finish and really break down
and understand what's actually happening within the cluster.
Your
description of, you know, the resource metrics, the
custom metrics, and the external metrics was all
fantastic. That's something that I've had a little
bit of confusion about in the past. So
it was good to kinda have that explained
to me in really nice detail.
Why don't well, we just wait for more
and more minute. Like, tell us a little
bit about seg auto scaling.
How long have you been in the chair?
What does that mean? And, you know, can
people get involved?
Yeah. Definitely.
We're
definitely always looking for more people to get
involved if people have,
like, use cases that aren't currently covered by
the the
components we all we take care of. So
we the signal to scaling currently has ownership
of the cluster autoscaler,
the HPA code within core Kubernetes,
vertical pod autoscaler,
and something called the
pod mani
slash add on resizer, which is a really
sort of
simple slash dumb
DPA, basically. So basic basically, it just scales
up and down in proportion vertically in proportion
to the size of the cluster or something
similar.
We there's there's some plans for for
us in terms of, like, what our what
our
near timeline looks like. We want to so
you saw a lot of those APIs we
were using were b two beta two.
Auto scaling b two beta two, API has
been around in beta for quite a long
time. We want to look at promoting
that to GA.
There's some bits of functionality that are still
in alpha that we want to try and
get into
beta and GA
to
basically enable people using managed services, a lot
of which
decide
to restrict people to beta and above
feature flags. We want to try and get
those
promoted
so that people can make use of them
wherever they're running.
And, yeah, we we've had a lot of
functionality and new best functionality pushed through by
users saying we we want best. There's there's
I I've not included it in the demos
yet, but there's some really cool functionality called
scale policies where, basically, you can get really
granular with how you want a pod a
service or a deployment to scale up and
scale down. So you can say, at most,
I want,
like, to scale down 10%
of the pods in this deployment or
eight pods at a time, whichever is the
highest or the lowest. So there's a lot
of granularity you can get in that and
that users have implemented.
So, yeah, I've been
co chair of the
six since
earlier this year, April time, maybe.
Time time has lost all meaning, like,
everyone.
And yeah, I I've tried to sort of
bring
a more end user focused
sort of
view of things because a lot of the
a lot of the people with heavy involvement
and maintainers of the code are very much
like Google.
Like, they're providers and they get feedback from,
like, users of g c e and g
c k
GKE. Sorry. But, like, I've I've tried to
sort of bring a more like, I'm I'm
dealing with clusters
and Skyscanner day
to day. So yeah.
Alright. Thank you. We we have office hours
every Monday
at
4PM
Central European time.
Come along if you have any
any ideas,
things you want to discuss.
Alright. Thank you very much.
We got a comment slash
question. I'm not sure.
So firstly, Justin says custom metrics is my
favorite. Yeah. I can definitely understand why custom
metrics and very powerful demo that we had
there.
And then idea cron based horizontal pod or
scaler, changing the scale policy on a cron
interval.
Yeah.
Think there's there's maybe a use case for
that. I mean, I can think if you're
an e commerce or you're a news outlet,
you might wanna scale set differently between office
hours between nine to five as you and
and maybe you wanna lower your skill and
policies in the in the evening or during
the night. Yeah. Definitely. Called you. Alright.
I know you've got another call to get
to and we've been overtime. So thank you
for sticking with me and for having sharing
your knowledge of us. That was really really
good.
And other people can check out that repository,
have a play, and and enjoy. Yeah. Then
let me know what is lacking.
Obviously, I need to go back and revisit
the limits for those stress deploys and figure
out why rabbit doesn't work on
it hits that.
If you would like a bare metal cluster
to play with, I will make one all
for you. Not a problem.
Alright. You have a a great day, guys.
Thanks again for joining and sharing your knowledge
and I'll speak to you again soon. Bye
bye. Thanks. Bye.